husbands who complain about having zeros
have no idea how the females strive
actually works and the complaining makes
it much worse my favorite thing is when
couples come in and they haven't had in
a year and I ask why and she looks at
him and says because he hasn't asked and
he says well I kind of hinted and you
just never seemed interested and she
says well when was the last time you
spent time with me well why would I
spend time with you if you're not having
sex with me and that right there is
exactly the spiral women after one year
their Strife switches from bonding with
you mode to long-term stability and mate
retention if you have given her the
adequate emotional bonding her sex drive
will go way up because her brain says
keep this man around and have as many of
his babies as I can I've worked with
couples in their 60s they come in having
very little and they leave after a few
sessions having three or four or five
times a week because they improve their
actual emotional intimacy which leads to
better non-sexual physical intimacy
which then leads overwhelmingly to
sexual physical intimacy